in the year 1944 computers weighed as
much as 4,500 kilograms a modern laptop
weighs around 2.7 kilograms what is the
ratio of how much computers weighed in
1944 to how much a modern laptop weighs
express your answer as a ratio of two
integers so the ratio of how much
computers weighed in 1944 so we know
that's 4,500 kilograms 4,500 kilograms
we want the ratio of that to how much a
modern laptop weighs and thats 2.7
kilograms so this right over here is a
ratio but we haven't expressed it as a
ratio of two integers in particular
4,500 is an integer but 2.7 is not an
integer so the easy way to convert 2.7
to an integer is to move the decimal
place one to the right or another way of
thinking about it is to multiply it by
10 so we could multiply this by 10 but
that would if we just multiply the
denominator by 10 that would change the
value of the ratio in order to not
change the value we have to multiply the
numerator and the denominator by 10 this
is equivalent to just multiplying this
fraction by 10 over 10 which is the same
thing as 1 does not change the value so
what do we get well in the numerator
4500 times 10 is 45,000 put a comma here
makes it a little bit easier to read and
in the denominator this is the whole
point of why we multiplied by 10 to
point 7 but multiplied by 10 is 27 so we
now have expressed our ratio or we've
now expressed our answer as a ratio of
two integers so this is completely
legitimate but we could also simplify
this just looking at this it looks like
45 45,000 is divisible by 45 which is
divisible by 9 and 27 is also divisible
by 9 so why don't we divide the
numerator and the denominator both by 9
and we're going to get so we're going to
divide by 9 in the numerator and we're
going to divide by
9 in the denominator and we are going to
get 45 divided by 9 is 5 so 45,000
divided by 9 is 5000 so we're going to
get 5,000 5,000 over 27 divided by 9 is
3 and I think we have now simplified
this about as much as we can